[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
The Silver Play Button is an award
given out by YouTube to channels
who reach 100,000 subscribers.
Well, for whatever reason,
we happen to have an additional
or extra Silver Play Button,
and so, we are going to see
what happens if we melt this down.
[Music]
The channel JerryRigEverything
did some tests,
and found that these old-style play buttons
are made of about 95 percent nickel.
So, we're going to throw it into
our furnace and see what happens.
Our furnace only gets up to
about 2,000 degrees,
whereas the melting point of nickel
is more like 25 or 26 hundred degrees.
Those are both in Fahrenheit.
But we do want to see what
happens if we just heat it up to 2000.
Maybe it gets soft.
Maybe it starts glowing.
I'm curious if the finish
is going to get destroyed,
and then if this furnace doesn't work,
we have our backup arc furnace,
which definitely gets
hot enough to melt it down.
So if it doesn't melt here,
and we'll try melting it there.
Pretty straightforward.
Let's put our play button down in there,
fire up the furnace and
see what happens to it.
[Music]
That was kind of cool right when it lit,
it like fogged up.
And I thought like,
"Oh! It's already ruined."
But then it just cleared right up.
So I guess that was
just some sort of vapor.
[Music]
Oh!
That. Look at that.
The top corner is-- Oh! On the edges.
Yeah starting to like bubble now.
So I'm pretty sure the surface
is actually also made of nickel,
but it's like a cleaner nickel plating
that's applied in a different method.
It's not cast with the rest of it.
So they probably, in a mold,
they cast the main button,
and then they plate
over the whole button.
Now, we're getting
some iridescent effects.
Yeah, that surface is
getting kind of wrecked.
[Music]
Neat.
That looks awesome.
[Music]
Ooh! Wow!
I think this is melting.
[Music]
Yeah, the inside of the
cup is now full of liquid.
[Music]
Oh well so much for this
just being a solid piece of nickel
that melts at 2,600 degrees.
That took about three minutes
to completely liquefy.
[Music]
So that makes me think
maybe this one is zinc,
which melts at about
700 degrees Fahrenheit
instead of 2600 degrees Fahrenheit.
[Music]
This right here was the
surface of the play button.
About half of it.
[Music]
Well, it started out as silver shiny metal,
and it's silver shiny metal again.
Fascinating!
Overall, this has been pretty surprising.
I really didn't think that was
going to melt in this furnace at all.
But it did.
In fact it melted in like
two, maybe three minutes.
It just turned into a
puddle down in the cup.
All of the shell that was
around It didn't melt.
It sort of fell in and ended up
as slag down in the cup
surrounded by molten metal,
but I'm going to see if I can
take this molten metal,
and I'm going to pour it
into a bowl full of Orbeez,
and I just want to see what comes out,
and then if we can
get a cool cast out of it.
[Music]
Three, two, one.
Oh!
[Music]
Oh! Limited--
Limited use on those  glass
containers full of molten metal.
Now, I got Orbeez
spilled all over the place.
Let's grab some cool
water and cool that off.
[Music]
This is just a little chunk
of glass from our bowl,
just stuck into the metal here.
I want to pry it out,
but I don't want to push
too hard with my fingers
'cause I'll probably end up
just cutting myself on it.
[Music]
Well, here is our Silver Play Button.
It's-- it's a little bit changed shape,
doesn't look quite the
same way it did before,
and because of how
low temperature this melted.
I'm now quite curious
about what metal this is.
I'm thinking it might be zinc,
or maybe even just tin,
which has a very low melting point.
But that melted so quickly and so easily
that I'm positive it wasn't nickel.
Because our furnace doesn't even
get hot enough to melt nickel.
So yeah, might have to do some tests
to try and figure out just what this was.
It still is. It's still metal.
It's just not a play button anymore,
but I don't know,
maybe that would look good,
just on a plaque on the wall too.
I want to display this.
Let's build a little display for this thing.
This is going to be fun.
[Music]
Our Silver Play Button has been
melted down and cast into a new shape,
and I gave that a nice little stand.
So we've got ourselves like a new award.
What do you think?
Should YouTube keep
giving out this style?
Or maybe should they move on to this one?
I don't know.
Maybe it's an upgrade.
Maybe not.
But I like how it turned out.
I am curious.
I'm gonna have to do some tests to
find out what kind of metal this is
because it's definitely not nickel.
So maybe this was a different
edition of the play button
than the one that
JerryRigEverything tested.
In fact, I bet pretty strongly that it is.
So, we'll have to do some tests of our own
and find out what this one is made of.
Guys. That's not all,
we've got more for you to see.
That little box up at the top
transports you directly to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The box is the bottom shows you what
YouTube thinks you need to be watching next,
and this bomb here in the middle
will subscribe you to the channel.
So you never miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring the bell
and we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.